[Musique]
dinara safina mais au contraire regardez
le plateau dans quel état les le plateau
c'est incroyable j'ai jamais vu le
bateau comme ça temps frais c'est un
truc de ouf chocolat partout partout
partout partout partout
[Musique]
les gains s'expliquent pour aller livrer
un client tu verras au rond point tu
prends la première à droite
je suis perdu dans la forêt les gardes
y'a pas d'un restaurant n'y a rien ici
je peux pas à livrer bon alors comme
tout beau comme tout bon livre war qui
se respecte je passerai chez vous entre
8 heures et 16 l'a vu le film il va me
dire bonjour vu le film evander bojan
pour devrait s'en tirer
mais je me sentirai perdu son rêve
[Musique]
ça faisait longtemps
madame lopez bonjour on a fini le boulot
fracassé bras alors lui revient pas de
martinique mais regardez il a l'air
vraiment tu reviens de toi d'ailleurs
pourquoi l'a t bonds mais ya pas de ré
mais il ya toute une région voire garde
je passerais bien
[Musique]
vient d'europe challenge exactement les
revenus que pour l'émission je suis
revenu que pour l'émission de gamekult
et 3 h le week end
puis les revenus de rance elle est
revenue de martine aubry
les photos sont dégueulasses il va
passer en titre ont encore sombré comme
ça on n'a pas ça allô allô
[Musique]
regardez le complice
[Applaudissements]
mais avec des vents de la sema c'est ma
première en chocolat tu sais moi m'a
aidé à moi j'étais à paris c'est paris
paris paris plage pari fait par email un
vrai parisien
voilà ça m'a pour tu peur mais permet
soirée vins sont belles mais permettez
moi il termine à la nati quarémont il en
prix du fer mais bon là c'est dur car on
relâche et l'odeur mais à vous désirez y
avait des yeux en prison zagré
enchantera monaco monaco maire
m'accueille d'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
et les amis alors c'est ça quelles
conditions s'est passé un examen voulait
pas tous les cas les dames et double
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]